>> SURYA: Hi, I'm Amanda Surya from Google
Developer Relations Team and in this video;
I will show you how you can utilize the YouTube
Direct Tool to solicit user generated video,
moderate relay submissions and display approved
videos on your website. Let's start by going
to YouTube Directs prio page where you can
download the latest code and read the Getting
Started Guide. The guide will walk you through
the steps of deploying your own instance of
YouTube Direct to Google App Engine, Google's
scalable hosting platform. Once you have successfully
deployed YouTube Direct to Google App Engine,
you can log in to the Admin interface. The
URL is going to be your appid.[INDISTINCT].com/admin.
Now, let's say that I have this blog about
travel to Asia and I want to solicit videos
from my readers around the topic. I will first
need to go to the admin panel to create a
new assignment. I'll set it to the right category,
set the status as active to enable video submission
and put a description to the assignment. Once
the assignment is created, I can get the app
loader code for that assignment and you copy
this code and paste it unto the page where
I want the app loader to appear,
click save, refresh and the app loader eye
frame appears on the page. Now, my readers
can start submitting their videos in response
to my blog post and they have two options
to do this. They can upload a new video or
submit an existing video that they already
own. Let me submit a video that I own under
my YouTube account. All I need to do is copy
and paste the URL. Once videos have been submitted
through the app loader, I can go back to YouTube
Direct Admin Panel to moderate the videos.
There's the video that I just submitted, the
status is unreviewed. As an admin, I can preview
the video and look at the details and once
I'm satisfied, I can approve it. Now that
I have an approved video, I can go back to
the assignment to get the code to display
the approved videos and you copy this code
and simply paste it unto my page,
refresh and as you can see, your true video
was automatically added to the playlist and
that completes our overview of YouTube Direct.
You can download the code at code.google.com/p/youtube-direct.
Thanks for watching.